in general what are the best ways to
have an uncredited writer
find script buyers well there are
i know that the contests have always
been a way to
get your work out there i think there
are a handful of
of contests like the nichols fellowship
um or nickel pickle fellowship um
[Music]
a few other contests that are there i
would you know i think any writers
starting off
we should go you can google it best
screenwriting contest
and see for yourself
and you know that's one way to do it i
mean the fees
you know the fees it's usually anywhere
between early entry fees are anywhere
between 40 and 60 bucks i don't think
they've fluctuated much in
in the last 15 20 years that's one way
to go
um i will say with the contests you got
to win
i think if you win it opens doors i
think even if you make it in the finals
i placed in a lot of contests
in in semifinals quarterfinals finalists
even
um in nickel right uh i was a
semifinalist to nickel
years back um with the pirate hunter
script believe it or not which was
a shock i just sort of submitted it for
poops and giggles
and went in and uh it made it uh
it made it all the way to semifinals i
had that was actually a film a script
that i had
co-written uh with an old friend of mine
and um
i was amazed because i know the nickel
always focused seemed to focus more on
you know drama maybe some comedy some
thriller but this was a straight
straight action movie um so i was
impressed that it uh
it got as far as it did
and it got me my first manager who is
still my dear friend
so it definitely opened some doors it
got me some meetings
um but i feel like you
still need to come away with the top
prize in that
um maybe a runner-up um
there's also uh for writers inc tip
which is a website that is devoted to
you know you put your logo you can
upload your logline synopsis you can put
a treatment and a script
and or i think it's treatment and or a
script up there
and that definitely there there are a
lot of
production companies who are on there
there's i think they have something like
15 000 members
and that you can subscribe they send
your log line out and you'll have people
come and
they can contact you i used to have some
stuff listed on there i had somebody
contact me
never really materialized but
there are people that are looking that's
one way to reach reach other folks
other than that you know i know it's
time of covid
networking is definitely a good way to
go uh it really is all about who you
know
um and um
you know that's that's that's a great
way and and
working working in an agency working in
a in a um
a production company um those
those are definitely ways of you
you can get your work to somebody
potentially
within those agencies companies etc that
might be able to open some doors for you
working working on shows
working on um a tv show uh working on a
film
um and continuing to work on various
productions
again you accrue a lot of people they
know it's what happened with me when i
started off
knowing going from one to the next to
the next and sort of broadening your
your scope of contacts um you know it's
a funny story i remember this is before
i even thought about being a tv writer
um i was on i had just left law and
order
um the law and order show after two
years and i
had given my script to a writer there
and um she got in touch with me a couple
months later she said you know i read
your script it's really good
she said have you considered tv writing
and at the time tv writing i just want
to write movies
and foolishly and this is something that
i say to
anyone watching if you have one of the
top tv writers on law order
or one of the tv writers in the business
and again this was before
the advent of like you know tv was
starting to come
to the fore and and you were starting to
get into the golden age but this was
like
probably a few years before that and i
was just so focused on being
film writer but this woman said to me
you know um and i i given her the script
because i admired and respected her
immensely and her talent
and she was one of the top writers there
i said she wrote she
she called me she said um
[Music]
this is really good and have you
considered writing tv and i said i
haven't
and she said well i would and i didn't
really heed that call until later and i
did write some pilots and i actually did
get some meetings with folks and tv and
some
at some of the networks with some of the
pilots i had written
but i wish i had heeded that call
earlier and some of your viewers are
probably
looking at this and saying what a
schmuck and you
yours are right what a schmuck if you
have that opportunity
you you hear those voices you they're
it's all signs
read the signposts if somebody says hey
you know what you may want to consider
writing this or working on that or you
know
take it because there are not a lot of
opportunities in the in
the film business and if you if you're
there to heed the call it could lead to
some really
uh potentially wonderful things
that's a great story yeah i mean maybe
just wasn't right for you at that time i
wouldn't
i was young and dumb and etc
that's all i'll say i had certain things
that yeah
if i think back but yeah she was a she
was a
i mean for her for her because i was
gone from the from the
the the um
the show at that time i was long gone
she did not have to call me
she did not have to call me up and
you know you know when i left i said to
her like i always i told her i said i
really appreciated
you know you really were inspiring to
work for you were always really
cool and and and and
and i admired who you were who you are
so i don't know if that did it but she
did get back to me she didn't have to
and she did
and she was just very complimentary and
i just wish
in hindsight you know maybe i had but
like you said i was in a different place
than i think i was 25.
yeah you know so and you're thick at
that and that's what i'm saying like it
there takes some maturation also do so
many things are being presented to you
at that age and and so i think there's
this weird skew that you think it's
always going to be
yes that way especially you do and
and you do you just think no i won't you
know i'll get that next opportunity in
three months
right you know something else right and
and you you look
you know the one thing i'll say is that
nobody ever said to me
and i'll still knock wood nobody ever
said to me stop writing
you just don't do it it's you need to
find a new career path nobody ever said
that to me
and i mean i guess we wouldn't really
say that to anybody but if somebody's
really being blunt sometimes they would
like you just don't have it you know and
i'm not saying i'm
i have it i'm just saying that in my
professional experience nobody ever said
just stop
this isn't for you sure and sometimes if
someone says it doesn't even mean
it's that somebody's trying to sabotage
someone so you just never know
what their opinion right what their
agenda is
and a funny and real funny story so that
script that
went to the semifinals in nickel
three months earlier we had somebody
submitted to this film production
company which is no longer around
and they made a couple of comedies that
weren't very good
but their director of development it's
though it is the meanest response i ever
received and it was my writing partner
and i at the time we received it
this development exec said it's
not such-and-such material
it's not this company's material i
remember thinking
and you made that film and you're and i
was i was so
one we went and i'll tell you i admire
my restraint
um because after we made it all the way
to the semifinals it was like
i still had a little bit of acid in my
mouth about that i just want to write oh
really well it's nickel material
but i didn't do that i'm not like that i
just but i was like
wow that was definitely
you know just i don't know if she meant
you know this isn't for us
you know but to just you know to go out
of their way and say this is not
this doesn't rise to our level i was
like
wow okay yeah you just wanted to put you
just wanted to put us down
all right all right well they're not
existence anymore so
we all got the last laugh because
somebody went to see their movies i
guess
but it was it was a really mean
mean-spirited thing to say i thought i
would never
ever say anything like that to anybody
it's a very conceited thing
yeah i almost feel like it's a hazing
and that's the only way i can think of
it is like you've got to have a bunch of
those to just keep you absolutely i'm
going to keep getting you know because
absolutely yeah it's it's they do happen
they do
you